or asked what is the constant of
proportionality between y and X in the
graph and just as a reminder when we're
talking about constant of
proportionality it sounds like a very
fancy thing but it's not too bad if
we're thinking about any XY pair on this
on this line let's say right over here
we have some X comma Y if Y is
proportionate or is proportional to X
then that means we can say that Y is
equal to some constant Y is equal to
some constant times X and that constant
that is our constant of proportionality
right over there sometimes you will see
this expressed if you divide both sides
by X sometimes you will see this as Y
over X is equal to the constant of
proportionality it shows if you for any
XY pair if you take your Y divided by X
what do you get that's the same same
thing so with that out of the way see if
you can answer their question what is
the constant of proportionality between
y and X in the graph well they very
clearly give us a point right over here
this point is the point 3 3 comma 2 and
so we could set it up a few ways we
could say look when y is equal to 2 X is
equal to 3 and so 2 would need to be
equal to some constant of
proportionality times 3 and if you
wanted to solve for this you just divide
both sides by the 3 so divide both sides
by 3 and you would get that your
constant of proportionality is 2/3
another way to do it right over here
well here we've kind of already solved
for our constant of proportionality when
Y or would you say when X is 3 when X is
3 y is equal to 2 in either case our
constant of proportionality is 2/3 let's
do another example so here we have which
line has a constant of proportionality
between y and X of 5 over 4 so pause
video and see if you can figure that out
so the key realization is we should test
points on these lines we should test XY
pairs and say well look if we take our Y
divided by X do we get 5/4 because that
would be our constant of proportionality
so let's first try let's fot try line a
right over here so line a then we find a
point that sits on it so that looks like
a point that sits on it and so if I take
this is the point 2 comma 5 and so if I
took Y divided by X I would get a
constant report constant of
proportionality as 5 halves so a is not
going to be our answer we want to get to
a constant of proportionality of 5/4 all
right let's try B ok B let me find a
point on B looks like this is a point on
B that is the point 4 comma 5 4 comma 5
and so in this situation K would be our
Y which is 5 divided by our X which is 4
so it looks like B is our choice for
kicks you could also look at the
constant of proportionality right over
here now there is one interesting
example that I just want to touch on
before we finish these examples what
about a situation where Y is equal to X
what is the constant of proportionality
then and what would it look like as well
as a line pause this video and think
about it
well there's really nothing new here
it's just you might not really see the
constant of proportionality when you see
it express this way but why Y is equal
to X is the same thing as Y is equal to
1 times X and so then it might jump out
at you that the constant of
proportionality is 1 in this scenario
right over here or if you took Y divided
by X Y over do it in that black color or
if you took Y over X you divide both
sides by X you would be left with the
constant of proportionality which would
be equal to 1 and if you wanted to graph
it well it would just look like this Y
would be equal to X for all X's so
that's what
when your constant of proportionality is
one you would those would represent
points on this orange line that I just
constructed